for
for those of us who have never visited
north korea all we've seen is the videos
all we've seen is you know we've read
about it we've seen articles about it
we've seen different things about it
what was it like for you growing up in
north korea
yeah so i think that was the almost like
the biggest challenge for me to talk
about my experience
in north korea is that sometimes i feel
like
it's even easier to explain about mars
or the moon to americans than north
korea
like north korea is a country that has
so many pieces right
the life the kim jong-un the dictator
has
is absolutely different from the
people's lives that
i had and my friends had so
i think today i i am only going to talk
about the people who are in the
and not in that privileged in a one
percent
class but the majority of north koreans
how they are actually surviving every
day
i think it's just almost like a
unimaginable
everyday life is a struggle
you know in north korea yeah when i was
growing up
there were even no words for depression
so or living stress so as i growing up
as a child when i came to south korea
they told me like stress is like
very big you know cause for something
depression is the like big main cause
for suicide and
i was like what is that and you don't
know what stress is like
what you don't know what depression is
and in north korea the regime
didn't put that words in the dictionary
for us so
you know imagine that in socialist
paradise
how can you possibly stress how can you
be possibly depressed
but in our real life is a struggle but
we just don't know how to put those like
concepts into words
i think you know when i was a child
first very first thing that my parents
my mom told
me was not to even whisper
because the mo the birds and mice could
hear me
and as a young girl the first thing i
learned is that
the most dangerous thing in my body that
i got is my tongue
what if i sleep some wrong words
that is not gonna only kill me that is
not gonna only kill my family
it is going to care three generations of
of my family if somebody say one wrong
thing
political statement is not gonna just
kill
that person it kills entire three
generations of that family
and that is like so in that sense i
never knew what you know
freedom of speech was i somehow thought
that's how a normal word was
because there was no internet obviously
i never heard the word internet in north
korea
there is only one channel on tv
24 hours that is telling us
how wonderful the socialist paradise is
and how bad our american ambassador's
enemies are and you know
i remember when i came to america going
to walmarts
and going to see this like section of
magazines
right they have living like fashion
magazine
cook magazine i've never seen any kind
of mags in north korea
like i've never seen a cookbook there's
like i never heard of
what modeling was like there's no
fashion magazine
the regime the government telling us
what to wear
what kind of haircut you can have what
kind of makeup you can have what kind of
pants you can wear
what kind of song you can sing what kind
of movie you can watch
what kind of dance you can dance every
little thing
is determined by the regime even before
i was born
and even where i live who i can marry
what can i do in life is determined by
my political class in the
in the country so telling americans that
although people who free people like
they think you know
like you choose what major you study
what clothes you wear everything for
them is so natural but coming from north
korea
even picking up a pants was a struggle
for me like
how i choose among like 10 different
pants they are selling how do i choose
like what i like
because in north korea nobody asks me
like what do i think